Das sind Jahreszeiten aus Jamaika, jetzt in
Europa, und Sie sind die
ganze Zeit zusammen mit einem Gentleman auf Tour oder
an manchen Tagen getrennt, oder
was ist jetzt in Europa geplant? Okay,
zunächst einmal ist dies meine zweite Tour,
okay  Meine Herren hier in Europa und
die erste Tour war 2011. Ich war nur ein
besonderes Geschenk. Wir tourten durch ganz Europa. Wir
haben mehrere Shows gemacht, aber dieses Mal habe ich
meine besondere Vermutung, wieder mit ein paar kleinen
Gigs auf eigene Faust, okay, und eure Geschichte ist
eine lange Geschichte  Ihre Freunde seit
ungefähr 18 Jahren, okay und
Gentlemen kam zuerst nach
Jamaika, wollte mit einigen Produzenten arbeiten und
ich war einer der ersten Produzenten und ersten
Produzenten, der Gentleman aufgenommen und
eine Kombination mit ihm gemacht und ihn dazu gebracht hat,
ein paar zu machen  Songs mit anderen jamaikanischen Künstlern
und es war heute irgendwie ungewöhnlich, mich
und andere zu einem Künstler zu machen, weil ich sagte,
weiße Typen aus den Deutschen machen
Reggae
Gentleman de Nada war sein Talent, sein
Talent war erstaunlich, denn es ist nicht
verwunderlich, dass viele, viele Menschen aus
der ganzen Welt Reggae machen wollen, aber
was immer das Problem ist, ist ihre
Fähigkeit, auf angenehme Weise
für uns als Jamaikaner zu liefern, okay, weil man
es muss  Denken Sie daran, unsere Musik ist nicht
unbedingt die englische Sprache,
die sie antreibt, sondern der Dialekt von Jamaika,
der ein Patois ist, okay, und aus irgendeinem
Grund ist der Gentleman sehr
echt und authentisch rübergekommen, wenn es darum geht, wie
die Musik sein sollte, wie sie sollte
Sound und so so, als ich ihn
meinen anderen Freunden wieder vorstellte, waren sie irgendwie
nicht so scharf darauf, eine Kombination zu machen,
aber sobald sie ihn seinen Stil
des DJings und alles andere
dazu hören, macht es ihn irgendwie  einfach für
ihn und dann meine ich die Welt nein nein dass
er ein gutes gutes wohl ist okay und berühmt
auf dem ganzen Planeten ist er berühmt und
das sage ich der Welt nein nein
damit die ganze Welt die große
Geschichte versteht  nt von Gentlemen und ich gehe zurück an
Bord. 18 Jahre lang waren wir immer
in Kontakt, aber es ist bis vor zwei
, zweieinhalb Jahren auf meinem Sonnenpass, Sie
wissen, ob die Verbindung zurückkam, weil
ich Ihr Sohn ermordet wurde  Jamaika ja
ja leider wurde er ausgeraubt und
ermordet und es war eine der
herausforderndsten Zeiten für mich und mein guter
Freund Gentleman hat sich an mich gewandt und
das war für mich eine der größten
Einladungen an den Erzeugten, als er
mich einlud zu kommen  Europa und
mit ihm auf Tour zu sein, war ein perfekter
Rückzug aus der Situation, weißt du, was
ich hatte, die Herausforderungen, die ich
hatte, als du kennst, eine Tante von
der kam dieses schöne Lied, du lebst
dein Leben, weil dieses Lied herauskam
einer natürlichen Erfahrung, die Sie wissen, weil ich
damit konfrontiert war Ich war an diesem Scheideweg Ich
wusste nicht, was ich tun sollte Ich würde sagen, das ist
eine der schwächsten Zeiten in meinem Leben
Ich war schon immer ein positiver Typ, aber zu
dieser Zeit war ich es  sehr unsicher fühlen sehr
schwach sehr  zweifelnd und ich war gerade an einem
Scheideweg, wie ich sagte, und diese eine Stimme
, die mir sagte, ich muss aufstehen und
dein Leben leben, also kam das Lied,
lebe dein Leben, und ich habe, ich bin ein Gentleman,
an dem ich teilhaben kann  it und er hat sich
seinen Part ausgedacht und wir fangen an, ihn live
auf der Welt zu spielen, bevor wir überhaupt ins Studio gegangen sind,
also habe ich das
in meinen fast 30 Jahren wieder
im Musikgeschäft noch nie gemacht und ich habe das noch nie
gemacht  Ich bin noch nie so an einen Song
herangegangen und es war ein sanfter Vorschlag eines Mannes,
was wir an dem Song so natürlich finden und es
fühlt sich so gut an, dass wir es
in unsere
Setlist aufnehmen sollten  Es war nicht, bis wir
nach Polen gingen, um vor einem
Publikum von fast 800 Leuten, 800.000
Leuten, 800.000 Leuten aufzutreten. Hey, ich habe sogar ein
Problem, es auszudrücken, weil es so
erstaunlich ist, weißt du,
achthunderttausend zweihunderttausend weniger eine Million
Leute, ich '  Ich habe nie diese Tiefe gekannt,
also ist das möglich, Sie wissen es aber  Es
passiert Woodstock in Polen und ich werde
das Lied spielen. Ich meine, die Leute können
es sich immer noch auf YouTube ansehen. Sie wissen, dass sie
beweisen, dass es da ist, und es war erstaunlich, es ist
eine meiner größten musikalischen Erfahrungen, also haben
wir das gemacht und daraus entstand das
Video  Die Leute schauen immer noch zu Die
Leute sind immer noch erstaunt darüber Ich
schaue immer noch zu Ich bin immer noch erstaunt darüber Hey und
ich hoffe es tut dir leid du siehst das Ich
denke es ist okay Beeindruckend Es ist
fantastisch Okay also die Leute kamen
und ich sah es einfach  Lebe dein Leben Richie
Steam Engine Commanders und nach den
festgelegten Zeiten nach dem Tod deines Sohnes habe ich
mit Herren darüber gesprochen, ob
es etwas ist, dass dein Sohn dir diese Erfahrung zurückgibt,
die du mit diesem Lied gemacht hast.
Viele Leute bezeichnen meinen Sohn als  Mein
Schutzengel ist jetzt in Ordnung, weil
es zuallererst nicht mein biologischer Sohn ist, ja, es ist
ein Adoptivsohn, der inoffiziell adoptiert wurde,
weil ich in Jamaika aufs Land
gegangen bin. Ich lebe gut in der Stadt, also bin ich
in meiner Heimatstadt aufs Land gegangen
und ich bin bei dem siebenjährigen Kind und
er sprach mit mir und argumentierte mit mir
wie jemand, der 20 ist, und ich war
überwältigt von seiner Intelligenz und seiner Fähigkeit
, jemanden wie mich zu überzeugen, und ich
brachte ihn zurück in die Stadt, die  war
ungefähr vier Stunden von mir entfernt und
von diesem Tag an war er
ungefähr
18 Jahre 17 18 Jahre bei mir, also wurde er
inoffiziell mein Sohn. Ich schickte ihn zur Schule. Ich
behandle ihn genauso wie meine anderen Kinder, von denen
ich fünf Kinder habe, okay  leibliche Kinder, also war
er wirklich mein Sohn, weißt du, und
es war wieder der traurigste Tag meines Lebens
und etwas, das ich daten, und ja, ich
glaube, aus dieser Situation heraus gibt es
definitiv ein neues Ich, da ich es jetzt erlebt habe
, wahrscheinlich, wenn es so ist  Wäre nicht
diese Situation,
die ich nicht erleben könnte, hätte ich nicht mein drittes Auge jetzt
weit geöffnet. Ich habe in
dieser Zeit etwas gelernt, dass das Unterrichten unbezahlbar ist
, weißt du, also sagte einer meiner guten Freunde
zu mir, ich singe jetzt  von einem anderen
Ort und wenn es mich ansieht  eine
andere Person sehen, okay, also ist etwas
Mystisches passiert, das ist das perfekte
Wort, es ist mystisch, es ist eine mystische Sache,
passiert. Ich kann es nicht in einfachen Worten erklären,
aber seine Tiefe bedeutet etwas anderes.
Ich weiß, was ich im Leben erlebe, okay, hast du das Gefühl, dass du ein
neues Album hast? Ja, es heißt echte Reggae-
Musik. Echte Reggae-Musik. Fühlst du das
immer noch
?
Es gibt einen Freund, den ich habe, der es
immer gesagt hat, und jetzt höre
ich es von anderen Freunden und Fans,
dass es etwas Neues an meiner
musikalischen Herangehensweise gibt, und was das für
mich bewirkt hat, ist mehr Disziplin, mehr Zeit für
meine Musik und was auch immer sie wahrgenommen wird  zu
sein, das ist es, aber dieses Album ist
Reggae-Musik. Lassen Sie mich Ihnen etwas über
das Konzept erzählen. Es ist ein Konzept, bei dem
wir auf das Wesentliche zurückgehen. Es gibt
einige Rhythmen darauf, einige Rhythmus-Tracks
das in den 60ern gebaut wurde und
einige von denen, die ich selbst produziert habe
und einige Songs dazu geschrieben habe, und
der, der neu erstellt wurde, sind im Grunde
auf die ursprüngliche Art und Weise gemacht, sodass Sie die
Hardcore-Wurzel der Reggae-Musik bekommen, egal ob
sie in ist  eine kulturelle Farm oder die Rockfarm eines Liebhabers,
aber darum geht es beim Konzept
des Albums, also sollten
die Leute es sich anhören, es ist ein sehr ernstes Album,
es ist auf dem Kingstone-Label, okay, ich bin
sehr aufgeregt, es zu hören, ja, also vielen Dank,
ich  Ich wünsche dir viel Erfolg mit
diesem Album und ja, vielleicht hören wir
dich auf deiner Tour in Europa. Danke,
dass ich hier bin. Danke, danke für mich